former farc rebel william muriel is
rightly proud of his pig farm it's one
of three projects he started with
hundreds of other demobilized fighters
investing the roughly two thousand
dollars each they received as part of
their agreement to disarm
we are selling an average of 160 pigs a
month 40 per week of around 105 kilos we
hope that with the two new sites we will
reach 100 or 120 a week
william says reaching this point has
been very difficult approval for the
project arrived only a year ago after
long fights with a bureaucracy he says
was set up to fail them
this government has done everything
possible to make the deal fail if it
wasn't for the united nations and the
international cooperation that are
guarantors of the process i wonder if i
would be here
the government signed its historic peace
deal with the farc five years ago
bringing to an end a conflict that
killed more than 200 thousand people
over more than five decades but many of
the hopes of that day are unfulfilled
even though most combatants have laid
down their arms
by addressing poverty and inequality
promising roads schools and jobs in many
neglected rural areas of the country the
peace deal was supposed to end the root
causes that fueled the war but five
years later little has changed
many accused the conservative government
of ivan duke of slow walking the deal's
implementation
studies show that just four percent of
the promised rural reform measures are
complete
while cocaine production is at an
all-time high and new armed groups and
farc dissidents are perpetuating new
cycles of violence
many reintegration camps are mostly
empty after former fighters moved away
under threat by armed groups
like claudia cruz with former comrades
has been trying to start a fish farm
first they were forced to leave their
camp then their leader was killed
[Music]
we live in fear this is worse than
during the war back then we could at
least defend ourselves after five years
i thought we would have a place to live
a little land and basic security we feel
disillusioned yet we endure
but despite their enduring commitment
success for them and the country remains
elusive and a lasting peace is not
guaranteed alessandra
al jazeera caldono calca